so I had the pleasure of visiting people
from neo core games the other week these
are the folks that make the incredible
adventures of Van Helsing they were kind
enough to show me the incredible
adventures of Van Helsing 3 which of
course I will now just refer to as van
Helsing 3 of course it's an action RPG
in the style of Diablo but one of the
things I think that has made the series
standout at least a little bit is
storytelling and not just from a
straightforward standpoint but from an
environmental standpoint van Helsing 3
of course takes place in sort of a myth
mythological Eastern European setting if
you will very dark very gothic what was
interesting of course is the the focus
on storytelling in van Helsing 3 then
you might be used to in something like
say path of Exile or something in Diablo
3 so neo course showed me three
different maps that are going to be in
van Helsing 3 as far as I could tell
they were the beginning of the game
followed by the the two sequences that
come after and one thing that struck me
was such a small thing but I think a
meaningful thing is just the way they
used the camera during cutscenes
typically in an action RPG you might see
the camera zoom in and you might see
characters speak to each other and then
it will zoom out in this case in van
Helsing 3 you saw the camera sway a
little bit from further behind and what
that did and again it seems like such a
small thing but it made me interested in
what was going on it didn't seem like
they were just trying to get the story
out of the way to move on to the action
it felt like you know this is something
that's worth paying attention to and of
course it is worth paying attention to
in this case because you have your
ghostly companion as well as a van
Helsing himself however in this case
there's there's something more to Van
Helsing 3 in the past there were three
character classes that you could choose
from in the third and final game you get
to choose from six classes the class
that I got to see was the elementalist
and the elementalist as you can imagine
is all about elemental magic with an
emphasis on fire and that came through
as I watched neo core play the game in
front of me for example one of the
biggest spells that I saw time and time
again
was a wall of fire and you don't just
cast the wall of fire but you draw it on
to the screen and that was sort of a
nice touch that enabled you to determine
the trajectory and how you were going to
damage enemies and one of the upgrades
for that spell that I saw later were the
fire snakes that would emerge from that
wall of fire and start spewing orbs of
fire at nearby enemies
I saw three levels in total the first
was a dungeon area and it was in this
case a place that you needed to be so
that you could break out a character
from the previous games out of his cell
and afterwards we then went to the hub
area and the hub area works a lot like
it did in van Helsing - van helsing -
had a tower defense minigame that you
could participate in there it's not
required but it's something that has
returned in van Helsing 3 however I
didn't get a chance to look at it at all
so I can't say whether or not the tower
defense aspect has improved in any way
or has had anything meaningful added to
it so the second area I saw was a forest
and it was a traditional action RPG kind
of place where you got some some
monsters that you might have seen before
such as centaurs and the like so the
third area was the most interesting it
was the most otherworldly sort of a
parallel dimension that you have to move
through in order to get to the next part
of the forest and in this case it also
gave me a chance to see some of the more
unusual enemies and creatures my
favorite of which is one that actually
the elementalists spawns for combat
called neter hoons I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing that but in any case
nether hounds and of course they were
helpful in addition to the snakes that
rose from the flames and spewed fire
outwards and ultimately after all of
this my takeaway was hey
then Helsing looks like another fun
action RPG in a series that has already
given us two fun action RPGs so yes I'm
looking forward to playing the
incredible adventures of Van Helsing on
the surface it looks pretty much like a
standard action RPG but I think when it
comes to action RPGs it really comes
down to the
details and in this case it seems like
the story details some of the visual
details and the world details are going
to be enough to keep me interested so
stay tuned a game spot I'll give you
more information as it comes
you
[Music]